since the beginning of humanity people
have been killing each other
are we going to keep this Behavior up
until the end of time
this mean that we cannot control our
violent instincts
maybe we would rather kill each other
it's mean that violence is an inherent
need for any human being you so
is there a monster within us waiting for
the right opportunity to eliminate his
enemies
or does this Bleak picture of human
nature exist for a hidden purpose
crashed into one of the towers
[Music]
[Applause]
I started boxing years ago
I felt the need to get rid of any
violent energy that haunted me
thod worked back then
and still does to this day
if everyone found something similar that
helped them just as boxing did for me
maybe the world would be less violent
[Music]
when faced with authority figure
two things that are horrible condenses
[Music]
it would be all about survival for
friendly that is our secret superpower
some people claim that humans are
inherently violent and that Civilization
is trying to keep their behavior
peaceful
others argue that people are actually
inherently peaceful and that
Civilization is the cause of their
violence
I wonder who is right
anthropologists say that the human hand
may have evolved to excel at delivering
a punch
does this mean that we are programmed to
fight
and is there anything we can do to
change that
violent events such as World War II LED
to experiments in the field of social
psychology
take the Milgram experiment as an
example
which focused on the conflict between
obedience to Authority and human
conscience
Stanley Milgram and his team at Yale
University recruited a group of
volunteers and instructed them to
inflict pain on others using electrical
shocks
the results seem to confirm the cruelty
of the human race
so is violence within Human Nature
or is it within our upbringing
scientists such as Anthropologist
Charles golden
have been researching the answer to that
question
hi Charles how are you well it's it's
great to be here first let's start by
defining what is violence
we consider violence as physical or
verbal aggression against another
individual do you think violence could
be an inheritance from our prehistoric
past there is a very basic
evolutionary need to protect ourselves
and that's what we call fight or flight
and we either run away or we attack
those who are attacking us and that kind
of violence obviously it leads to
survival so it's very important but
unfortunately when you become a social
animal and you interact with other
people a lot rather than being a
hunter-gatherer those Basic Instincts
become counterproductive and that is the
problem that we face today in dealing
with with Modern Men what is the
neocortex and can you tell me what is
its relation to violence the core
attacks around the brain he grew up to
allow us to become social creatures
allowed us to help develop speech it
allows us to develop our understanding
of social relationships it allows us to
solve problems and it also allows us to
control the Basic Instincts that are
deep inside the brain and then as we get
older and older we develop in theory if
the brain develops correctly we develop
the way to what we call inhibit those
areas of the brain so that we can sit
and say yes I'm angry yes I want to
injure that person or I have the impulse
to do it but I'm not going to do it what
did they want to prove exactly with the
Milgram experiment Milgram and many
people of that generation had just gone
through World War II and the idea was to
understand why would what appear to be
good people do things that the Nuremberg
trials and others labeled as horrendous
unbelievable levels of activities
towards others and Milgram showed
unfortunately that when faced with
authority figures faced with power
people will do things that are horrible
and justify that to themselves at the
time even though later when you talk to
them they say I don't understand why I
did that
in conclusion
is violence our inevitable fate whether
out of obedience fear or aggressive
instincts
we have no control over how violent we
can become
I cannot believe that
it is too scary
[Music]
I understand that there could be some
potential will for Destruction buried
deep within our nature
but I admit that the results of Stanley
milgram's experiment have left me in
shock
I am sure we are also capable of love
and compassion
that is why I need to dig deeper
[Music]
frankly I needed to take a closer look
at milgram's experiment
and I have managed to find somebody who
already has
is a historian and an author he recently
wrote a book titled humankind a hopeful
history
providing an optimistic historical
perspective on the last two hundred
thousand years of human history
I am eager to hear what he has to say
Hi rudkar how are you Hi Emil so great
to see you do you think we are born
violent or we are raised into it
this is really one of the oldest and
deepest questions you can ask one of the
most influential theories in Western
culture says that our civilization is
just a thin layer you know just a thin
veneer and that below that thin line of
civilization lies our raw human nature
that deep down most people are just
selfish and nasty violent or even
monsters
um this is the idea that has come back
again and again and again in our culture
and um
I think that idea is wrong and why well
what has happened in the last I'd say 50
to 20 years is what you could call a
silent revolution in science there have
been a huge amount of scientists who've
been moving from a quite cynical view of
human nature of who we are as a species
to a more hopeful view it would be all
about survival of the friendliest that's
what scientists now believe that for the
biggest part of our history it was
actually the friendliest Among Us who
had the most kids and the biggest chance
of passing on their genes to the Next
Generation that is our secret superpower
would you say that we are improving as a
society and in relation to violence one
of the most interesting questions you
can ask as a historian is what makes
human beings special we like to believe
that we are very special because we're
super smart right so what scientists
have now come to believe that what
really is our superpower is not our
individual intelligence you know it's
our Collective ability to work together
and the reason we came better at
cooperating is because of this process
of survival of the friendliest the best
insurance policy you're gonna have
it's friends right friends are going to
help you through tough times so humans
are the only animals in the whole Animal
Kingdom with the ability to blush
which is quite striking right that our
cheeks can become red that we
involuntarily give away our feelings to
other members of our species now if you
if you have people are just selfish deep
down then why would we blush how could
there ever be an advantage well the
reason it's in Advantage for us is
because it helps us to cooperate right
it establishes trust between people so
there's no other animal in the whole
Animal Kingdom the blushes we are the
only ones that do it could you talk to
me about the Milgram experiment so
Stanley Milgram was a young scientist
and what he did he brought people into
the lab and he said look I want you to
do a simple test you know just a simple
memory test in reality something else
was going on you know the people were
put in a room where they had to push a
button on a shock machine and they could
see that you know the first shock they
would give to someone else was just a
small slight shock of 15 volts but then
if the person in the other room would
keep making mistakes the shock level
would go all the way up to 450 volts
which is lethal right and so the
shocking finding of Stanley Milgram was
that as much as 65 percent of people are
willing to go all the way up to 450
volts only if someone else tells us to
do it right so this was an
extraordinarily pessimistic experiment
and what doubts and controversies exist
around the results of this experiment
what we now know because a new
generation of scientists has gone into
the archives is that the experiment was
well almost a hoax
um so Gina Perry she's an Australian
psychologist she's discovered that
actually the majority of the
participants didn't believe the
situation was real probably this was
going on is it's a phenomenon that is
well known in science that when people
come into the lab as a subject you know
they're helpful they're friendly they
want to help the scientists to get the
results that they want but this is
obviously very dangerous right because
if people can guess sort of the goal of
the experiment
then uh you know the question is how
reliable are the results
so why do we keep talking about
milgram's experiment 60 years later when
science has seriously challenged its
findings
if we can't control the violence within
us
why is there this persistent idea that
we are more dangerous than we think we
are
why are we constantly being shown images
of violent people
why do the most horrific crimes get the
most attention is there someone who
wants us to think that we live under
constant threat from one another
and that we are worse than we really are
[Music]
we normally doubt strangers and expect
the worst of them maybe our human nature
is like that
we don't need any external factor to
teach or encourage us and maybe we as a
society are being toyed with
just to believe that stuff you are
talking about maybe there is a will that
wants us to always be doubtful and
scared
right right you look like a person in
search of someone to blame what I need
to look for
is someone to explain to me
who are the ones possibly manipulating
violence within the society
why would anybody manipulate us
interfering our neighbors and expecting
the worst from them
who benefits from this overstated
perception of violence
if we were this violent
would we appoint someone to control us
if we fear our neighbors for example
wouldn't we hire someone to protect
ourselves from them
[Applause]
from the beginning of history there is
the idea that if we weren't controlled
and protected by some Authority
we would fall into violent Anarchy in a
world of crime
both of which ruled with the same laws
as a jungle
but do we need we need leaders and
authorities monopolizing violence
to keep us safe or is it just an attempt
to control Society instead
do authorities still believe in
mildren's outdated findings or is it a
pretense to subject us to their
repressive forces to maintain the status
quo
in other words is the police there to
keep us safe or under control
or is it actually to serve another end
Erman is a researcher for Human Rights
Watch
and has worked as director of research
at the Arabic Network for human rights
information in Cairo
as well as a freelance journalist for
several Egyptian and international
Outlets
I'm confident he will help me find my
answers
um
a spot
[Music]
foreign
human hands might well be suited for
punching or fighting
however
you will also find them suitable for
shaking hands with another person
holding a child
or waving at a friend
[Music]
perhaps choosing to connect
see each other as equals and be equally
repulsed by violence might free us from
our fears and doubts
and free us from the ones who want to
keep us afraid and suspicious
[Music]
foreign